This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In downtown Providence, Rhode Island, there's a large plot of land that sits on the bank of the Unasquitucket River. In 1838, it was the home of the Rhode Island State Prison, which was notorious for its horrid smell, dreary outward appearance, and reputation for solitary confinement. Later, the land house, the continuing education campus for the University of Rhode Island. And after that, a dirt parking lot called Raise Park and Lock. Then in 1999, in a grand effort to revitalize the city, and with much fanfare, the Providence Place Mall was opened. That's Vanessa Lo, producer of the podcast, Nocturne. The mall costing $500 million was what was known as a super regional, a one-stop shopping
这里是《99%隐形》，我是罗马·马尔斯。在罗德岛州普罗维登斯的市中心，有一大片土地坐落在乌纳斯奎塔克特河岸边。1838年，这里曾是罗德岛州立监狱的所在地，它因恶臭难闻、外观阴暗以及臭名昭著的单人禁闭室而闻名。后来，这块土地改建成了罗德岛大学的继续教育校区。再后来，这里变成了一个名为“雷斯停车场”的泥土停车场。到了1999年，为了振兴这座城市，在盛大的宣传和万众期待中，普罗维登斯广场购物中心开业了。这是播客《夜曲》的制作人凡妮莎·洛。这座耗资5亿美元的购物中心被称为“超级区域中心”，是一个一站式购物
destination, housing everything consumers could possibly want or need in a totally enclosed space. Partially funded by taxpayer money, it's banned 13 acres, offered 1.4 million square feet of retail space, and dominated the riverfront. It was the largest construction project in Providence's history. This is this one building and we sort of stood in awe watching it get built. Michael Townsend is an artist who lived nearby when the mall was still under construction in the 1990s.
目的地，在一个完全封闭的空间里容纳了消费者可能想要或需要的一切。它部分由纳税人的资金资助，占地13英亩，提供了140万平方英尺的零售空间，并主导了河滨景观。这是普罗维登斯历史上最大的建筑项目。这就是这座单独的建筑，我们站在那里，敬畏地看着它拔地而起。迈克尔·汤森是一名艺术家，20世纪90年代购物中心还在建设时，他就住在附近。
His daily running route took him past the construction site, and Michael says that as he watched it go up, he had an open mind about the project. He was cautiously optimistic that it would be a welcome addition to the neighborhood. But yeah, that didn't last long. Yeah, it's funny. The revolving to a building like that doesn't really kick in until the skin gets put on. When, when something in its, in its director set mode, what are you just seeing the skeleton? Like, oh, that's a pretty cool skeleton,
他日常跑步的路线正好经过施工现场，迈克尔说，当他看着它一点点建起来时，他对这个项目抱持着开放的心态。他谨慎地乐观认为，这将为社区增添一个受欢迎的新成员。但好吧，那并没有持续多久。是的，这很有趣。对这样一栋建筑的情感转变，直到外墙装上时才真正开始发挥作用。当某个东西处于其导演设定模式时，你看到的只是骨架？就像，哦，那是个挺酷的骨架，
but as soon as the flesh is there, you're like, ooh, not pretty. Providence Place was going to be a big boxy stack of shops without much in the way of architectural niceties. And on his runs, Michael watched as that big box was slowly filled with the things that make them all a mall. As it's being built, I start to sort of do mental maps of spaces. That's going to be a story, that's going to be a storage space, that's going to be parking.
但一旦血肉有了，你就会觉得：哦，真难看。普罗维登斯广场原本会是一个巨大的、方块状的商店堆砌体，在建筑美学上没有什么可取之处。在他跑步的过程中，迈克尔看着那个巨大的方块慢慢被那些让购物中心成为购物中心的元素所填满。在它建造的过程中，我开始在脑海中对空间进行绘制。那将是一个店铺，那将是一个储藏空间，那将是一个停车场。
But amidst all the construction, there was one part of the building that kept catching Michael's eye, a weird space in the guts of the architecture that didn't make sense. I thought that was really odd. It didn't seem to meet the profile of either a storage space, or a parking space, or a store space. Michael wasn't sure what the space was for. It seemed to exist only by virtue of the walls intended for the more legitimate spaces around it, but the result was this room.
但在所有的建设中，建筑中有一个部分一直吸引着迈克尔的目光——建筑内部一个奇怪的、说不通的空间。我觉得这真的很奇怪。它似乎既不符合储藏空间、停车场，也不符合店铺空间的特征。迈克尔不确定这个空间是用来做什么的。它似乎仅仅凭借为其周围更合法的空间而设计的墙壁才得以存在，但结果就是这个房间。
It was an accidental room, a remainder left over by the long division of the mall's architecture. I had never seen anything like it, never time I ran by it, I was something I would think about. Michael eventually put the strange room out of his mind. He probably would have forgotten about it entirely, except that four years later, a second group of developers encouraged by the success of Providence Place set their sights even closer to Michael.
这是一个意外的房间，是购物中心建筑长除法过后留下来的剩余部分。我从未见过类似的东西，每次我从它旁边跑过，它都是我会思考的事情。迈克尔最终把这个奇怪的房间抛在了脑后。他本可能会彻底忘记它，但四年后，第二批开发商受到普罗维登斯广场成功的鼓舞，将目光投向了离迈克尔更近的地方。
This time, they wanted to build right on top of the historic mill district where Michael and a dozen or so other artists lived and worked in an old industrial building they called Fort Thunder. The developers had used a computer algorithm to figure out where to place a new supermarket so that it wouldn't compete with other supermarkets in the area. And I got to see this computer printout. And it's sort of like a nuclear explosion map.
这一次，他们想直接在历史悠久的磨坊区上建造，迈克尔和其他十多位艺术家就在那里的一栋名为“雷霆堡”的老工业建筑里生活和工作。开发商使用计算机算法来计算在哪里建造新的超市，以免与该地区的其他超市竞争。我看到了这份计算机打印件。它有点像核爆炸地图。
You can sort of see the radius from each supermarket and their theoretical reach. And in the blank spot that was our neighborhood, they put an X directly on the building we were living. And that was just the start. The developers wanted to tear down all of the old mill buildings and replace them with yet more retail with little to no pedestrian access. And it appears that the only mantra they have is if you see a space that's underdeveloped, you have a God-given responsibility to develop it. And it was basically like having a complete stranger be like, we've been thinking about
你可以看到每个超市的辐射半径及其理论覆盖范围。而在我们社区的那片空白区域，他们在我们居住的建筑上直接画了一个叉。而这仅仅是个开始。开发商想要拆除所有老旧的磨坊建筑，用更多的零售店取而代之，几乎甚至完全没有行人通道。他们唯一的座右铭似乎就是：如果你看到一个未充分开发的 espaço，你就有上帝赋予的责任去开发它。这基本上就像一个完全陌生的人对你说：我们一直在考虑
it. And we think we want to knock your house down. And make it a parking lot if it's cool with you. Now normally this would be the part of the story when we tell you that Michael and the other residents of Fort Thunder banded together to save their home in the face of the relentless march of capital. But no, it's not that kind of story. Granted, they did save some buildings, but as for Fort Thunder.
这件事。如果我们把你的房子推倒，把它变成一个停车场，如果你觉得没问题的话。通常情况下，这就是故事中我们要告诉你的时候：迈克尔和“雷霆堡”的其他居民联合起来，在资本的无情推进面前拯救他们的家园。但不是的，这不是那种故事。诚然，他们确实拯救了一些建筑，但至于“雷霆堡”。
Oh, we're actually home? Oh yeah, they f***ing leveled that. They came in with bulldozers in crane to knock that sucker flat. Fort Thunder was gone. The reason we're telling you this story is because of what happened next. Because when I see something like that I'm like oh oh really game on. Michael and his friends had lost their home and in their mind it had all started with that first mall. That was the original seeded development that
哦，我们真的回家了吗？哦是的，他们他妈的把它夷为平地了。他们带着推土机和起重机进来，把那个吸盘砸得粉碎。“雷霆堡”没了。我们之所以告诉你这个故事，是因为接下来发生的事情。因为当我看到类似的事情时，我会想：哦，哦，真的要开战了。迈克尔和他的朋友们失去了他们的家园，在他们看来，这一切都是从那个最初的购物中心开始的。那是最初的播种开发，
had led to everything else. And so talk began of a mall-related action. Call it art, call it a stunt, but a plan started to take shape. Michael and his friends decided that they would find a way to live in the mall for seven days. Yeah, live in the mall, and they said a rule for themselves. They couldn't leave. And without a second thought of thinking of how unfeasible that is, for our own well-being, we really felt that we had to do it. And if this sounds like a lark, well, yeah, it kind of was. But a secretly serious lark.
导致了后来的所有事情。于是开始讨论与购物中心相关的行动。称之为艺术，称之为特技，但一个计划开始成形。迈克尔和他的朋友们决定，他们要找到一种在购物中心生活七天的方法。是的，住在购物中心里，他们给自己定了一条规则：他们不能离开。而且没有一丝一毫去考虑这样做是多么不可行，为了我们自己的福祉，我们真的觉得我们必须这样做。如果这听起来像是一个恶作剧，嗯，是的，确实有点像。但这是一个秘密的严肃恶作剧。
The four friends, they would eventually number eight, wanted to assert that spaces like the mall could belong just as much to them as to the developers. To really do this right, they would need to find a space in the mall where they could hide themselves away, and Michael had the perfect place in mind. He began to search for that mysterious room that he'd noticed when the mall was under construction all those years before. He remembered seeing that the room was connected to a kind of crevice, a narrow gap in the
这四个朋友（后来增加到了八人）想要宣称，像购物中心这样的空间不仅属于开发商，也同样属于他们。要真正做好这件事，他们需要在购物中心里找一个可以把自己藏起来的空间，而迈克尔心中有一个完美的去处。他开始寻找那个神秘的房间，那是几年前购物中心施工时他注意到的。他记得那个房间连接着一条缝隙，那是
building structure that eventually led out to an exterior wall. So one night Michael went to see if the entrance to that crevice had ever been sealed off. Amazingly, it had it. It was small and sort of hidden, but there was still a crack in the exterior of the mall, and so he and his then- wife Adriana turned themselves sideways and slipped inside. And then once you're in at that point, you are exploring a system of caverns long, weird, vertical caverns.
建筑结构中的一条狭窄缝隙，最终通向一面外墙。所以一天晚上，迈克尔去查看那条缝隙的入口是否被封死。令人惊奇的是，它没有。它很小而且有点隐蔽，但购物中心的外墙上仍然有一道裂缝，于是他和当时的妻子阿德里安娜侧着身子溜了进去。一旦你进去了，那时你就在探索一个洞穴系统——漫长、奇特、垂直的洞穴。
And there are places where it just falls down into the lower levels of the mall. So you've got about a foot and a half of cliff. We are looking to a black abyss. And then this series of chambers ultimately give you access to this space. The room was tall and wide, filled with the byproducts of the mall's construction from years before.
有些地方它直接坠入购物中心的底层。所以你大约有一英尺半的悬崖。我们正看着一个黑色的深渊。然后，这一系列房间最终让你进入了这个空间。房间又高又宽，里面堆满了几年前购物中心施工时的副产品。
Broken two by fours and screws and plastic zip ties that hadn't even been worth removing. The space had literally been forgotten. And it was big. It was a big space that served no other purpose. It wasn't a storefront and it wasn't a stairwell. It was just big, and it was a thrill to physically find it. It'd be like, this is it. This is what I remember. The room was in the guts of the building. The part that no one was ever supposed to use, or even really see. But Michael and Adriana saw that it could still be accessed by multiple hidden entry points,
断掉的二乘四木材、螺丝和塑料扎带，甚至都不值得清理。这个空间真的被遗忘了。而且它很大。这是一个很大且没有其他用途的空间。它不是店面，也不是楼梯间。它只是很大，亲手找到它让人兴奋不已。就像：就是这个。这就是我记忆中的那个。这个房间在建筑的内部深处。那个根本不应该被任何人使用甚至真正看到的部门。但迈克尔和阿德里安娜发现，通过多个隐藏的入口仍然可以进入它，
including from inside the shopping center itself. If you knew how to get there, you could walk there from the maces, but as far as they could tell, they were the only people who knew this room existed. It was at that moment that the friend's schemes started changing. The initial plan had been to spend a week in the mall, but the way they saw it, they were sitting on 750 square feet of underutilized space, and then they asked themselves, what would a developer do? Because after all. If you see a space that's underdeveloped, you have a God-giver responsibility to develop it.
包括从购物中心内部进入。如果你知道怎么去，你可以从梅西百货走过去，但据他们所知，他们是唯一知道这个房间存在的人。就在那一刻，朋友们的计划开始改变。最初的计划是在购物中心度过一周，但在他们看来，他们正坐拥750平方英尺未充分利用的空间，然后他们自问：开发商会怎么做？因为毕竟。如果你看到一个未充分开发的 espaço，你就有上帝赋予的责任去开发它。
So, we decided that perhaps the absolute best thing we could do is to build a condo. I like that as that is always the answer. If you're not sure what to do with the space, just make it a condo. The new plan was no longer to live in the mall for a week. It was now simply to live in the mall for days at a time, using the room as an apartment. And while that may sound like a nightmare to everyone, but a few weird artists from Providence,
所以，我们决定，也许我们能做的绝对最好的事情就是建一套公寓。我喜欢这个答案，因为这总是标准答案。如果你不确定拿一个空间怎么办，那就把它变成公寓。新计划不再是在购物中心里住上一周。现在的计划很简单，就是一次在购物中心里住上几天，把这个房间当成公寓。虽然对除了普罗维登斯的几个怪咖艺术家之外的所有人来说，这听起来像是一场噩梦，
Michael and his friends got to work on this little project with the excitement of new homeowners. Step one, of course, was cleaning. They had to get rid of all that debris. It's sort of like, you know, like in a prison break movie, we were literally filling up our backpacks with just dirt and grime
但迈克尔和他的朋友们带着新房主的兴奋开始了这项小工程。第一步，当然是打扫卫生。他们必须清理掉所有的残骸。这有点像，你知道的，就像在越狱电影里，我们真的把背包里塞满了泥土和污垢，
and then carrying it out of the mall and getting rid of it. And for every backpackful of debris they took out, they'd bring a packful of something in. Gallant jugs of water for drinking and cleaning, clamplights and extension cords for illumination, which they plugged into the mall's internal power system. Parts for an ad-hoc kitchen, they even built a center block wall to hide the space from anyone else who might venture into the cavern complex from its various other entrances.
然后把它运出购物中心并扔掉。他们每带出一个背包的残骸，就会带进一个背包的东西。用于饮用和清洁的大桶水、用于照明的夹式灯和延长线（他们将其插入购物中心的内部供电系统）。临时厨房的零件，他们甚至建造了一堵中央砖墙，以防任何其他人从其各种其他入口冒险进入洞穴复杂时看到这个空间。
We went and got a door that was at exact mere of the doors they used in the mall. So if you were to find it, unless you were looking really closely at first glance, it just looks exactly like a, like it had been built originally. Finally, it was time to decorate. Anything we could buy at the mall we would. A low table came in on top of that proudly perch was a television and our PlayStation.
我们去弄了一扇门，那扇门与购物中心使用的门完全相同。所以如果你找到了它，除非你一开始就仔细观察，否则它看起来完全就像是一开始就建好的一样。最后，是时候进行装饰了。我们能在购物中心买到的任何东西，我们都会买。一张低矮的桌子被搬了进来，上面骄傲地摆放着一台电视和我们的PlayStation。
But if we couldn't buy it at the mall, we'd have to bring it into the mall. That's for the large pieces like the China Hutch or the fourth piece sectional couch No, but nobody looked twice so that you brought pieces of a couch through the mall How did you get that in there? in broad daylight we avoided the night and Sort of worked with the ebb and flow of the mall we were just part of the You know the living organism of its daily activities. Amazing risky trying to furnish a secret apartment with a nested coffee table, but to anyone
但如果我们不能在购物中心买到，我们就必须把它带进购物中心。至于像中式碗柜或四件套组合沙发这样的大件……不，但没有人多看一眼，你竟然把沙发的零件带过了购物中心？你是怎么把它弄进去的？在大白天，我们避开夜晚，顺应购物中心的潮起潮落，我们只是……你知道的，其日常活动的活生生有机体的一部分。用一个嵌套式咖啡桌来布置一个秘密公寓，这太疯狂、太冒险了，但对任何人来说
watching. It was just a person walking through a mall with a nested coffee table that they just bought at the mall. There's simply no such thing as a suspicious consumer item in a building that is dedicated to consumerism. The friends would sometimes stay in the secret apartment for several weeks in a row, just living, watching television, making collages with shadow boxes they bought at Pottery Barn, even cooking in the ad hoc kitchen. Michael remembers burning some waffles with a waffle iron and wondering if the smoke would give them away. And when the eight friends weren't enjoying their secret apartment, they were enjoying the mall, not as shoppers, but as residents.
看着。这只是一个人手里拿着一个刚在购物中心买的嵌套式咖啡桌走过购物中心。在一个专门致力于消费主义的建筑里，根本没有所谓的“可疑消费品”。朋友们有时会在秘密公寓里连续住上好几个星期，只是生活、看电视、用他们在Pottery Barn买的阴影盒做拼贴画，甚至在临时厨房里做饭。迈克尔记得用华夫饼机烤糊了一些华夫饼，并想知道烟雾会不会暴露他们。当这八个朋友没有在享受他们的秘密公寓时，他们就在享受购物中心，不是作为购物者，而是作为居民。
Thanks to its late night movie theater, the mall almost never closed. So sometimes they would just roam the building with no goal in mind, observing its many moods. There are times when that entire building probably had maybe 10 people in it, like in the middle of the night. There would be security officers, there would be cleaning staff. And it's a really wonderful time because it's like having a public park for levels deep all to yourself. And in those moments, there's a sense of ownership and I just feel really good.
由于其深夜电影院，购物中心几乎从未关门。所以有时他们会漫无目的地在建筑里闲逛，观察它的千姿百态。有时候，整个建筑可能只有大约10个人，比如在半夜。会有保安人员，会有清洁人员。这是一段非常美好的时光，因为这就像拥有一个四层深的公共公园，完全属于你一个人。在那些时刻，有一种所有权感，我感觉真的很好。
Weeks turned to months and eventually years. Out of the emotional rebel-affort-s Thunder, they'd finally found their refuge, and all thanks to the mall's developers, who had accidentally provided a sanctuary from the world they were busy developing. But as the old saying goes, there comes a time in every man's life when he must stop living at the mall. Unfortunately, the sea got planted that this whole thing was going to unravel. And that's because we had a break in. One day, they came back to the apartment
几周变成几个月，最后变成了几年。从“雷霆堡”事件的情感反叛中，他们终于找到了避难所，这一切都要归功于购物中心的开发商，他们无意中提供了一个庇护所，让他们免受他们正忙于开发的世界的侵害。但俗话说得好，人生的每个阶段都有必须停止住在购物中心的时候。不幸的是，整件事将要瓦解的种子已经种下了。那是因为我们遭到了入室盗窃。一天，他们回到公寓，
only to discover that someone had kicked open the door and stole in the PlayStation, along with several other small items, including the art they had made and a photo album. But they left the silverware, they left the TV, we're like, this is a very odd burglary. Like, they didn't take the things of value. They only took the, we're like, this is a very odd burglary. They didn't take the things of value. They only took the things that were like super personal.
却发现有人踢开门，偷走了PlayStation以及其他几件小物品，包括他们制作的艺术品和一个相册。但他们留下了银器，留下了电视，我们当时想：这是一次非常奇怪的盗窃。就像，他们没有拿有价值的东西。他们只拿了……我们当时想：这是一次非常奇怪的盗窃。他们没有拿有价值的东西。他们只拿了那些非常私人的东西。
Michael and his friends were spooked. They had managed to hide the apartment for four years, but now someone knew about the room, someone who could come back at any time and who seemed to be interested in them. So they changed things up. They decided from now on, they'd only stay there at night
迈克尔和他的朋友们吓坏了。他们设法把公寓隐藏了四年，但现在有人知道了这个房间，一个随时可能回来并且似乎对他们感兴趣的人。所以他们改变了策略。他们决定从今以后，只在晚上呆在那里，
when the chances of being caught were low, never during the day. And crucially, they would double down on another rule they'd had since almost the very beginning. Don't share it with anyone. Don't physically bring anyone here who wasn't involved in the making of it. So a lot of my very, very good and best friends
当被抓到的几率很低时，绝不在白天。至关重要的是，他们将加倍遵守从一开始就有的另一条规则：不要告诉任何人。不要把任何没有参与建造它的人带到这里来。所以我的许多非常非常好的和最好的朋友
never saw the space. And I'm the one who took that rule and broke it. Michael was hosting a visiting artist from Hong Kong. Her name was Jaffa. He was driving her to the bus station on her way out of town. And we're driving past the mall, and I say to myself, what can it hurt? How could this possibly backfire me? So I brought her into the space.
从来没有见过这个空间。而我是那个打破了这条规则的人。迈克尔当时正在接待一位来自香港的访问艺术家。她的名字叫贾法。他正开车送她去汽车站，她正准备离开小镇。我们开车路过购物中心，我对自己说：这能有什么伤害？这怎么可能对我不利呢？所以我把她带进了这个空间。
Her mind was absolutely blown. You gotta remember that this is at the peak of its build out. Michael showed Jaffa everything. The couch, the lights, the television. They were just days away from installing a water tank and a wood floor. In spite of the break-in, after four years of work, the apartment was on the verge of feeling like a real home. But when we're leaving, I hear a walkie-talkie on the other side of the door, with a two feet of us. And when the door opens, it's three dudes and ties and sports jackets.
她简直惊呆了。你得记住，这是在建设的鼎盛时期。迈克尔向贾法展示了一切。沙发、灯光、电视。他们距离安装水箱和木地板只有几天的时间了。尽管发生了入室盗窃，但在经历了四年的工作之后，这间公寓即将让人感觉像一个真正的家。但当我们离开时，我听到门另一侧对讲机的声音，距离我们只有两英尺。当门打开时，是三个系着领带、穿着运动夹克的小伙子。
And I realize in that moment, I internalize that it's over. It turned out that the earlier break-in had been the work of two of the mall's newest security cards. Instead of removing everything, they had been the work of two of the mall's newest security cards. Instead of removing everything, they had taken the personal items in hopes of figuring out who Michael and his friends were. Now that Michael had been foolish enough to come back during the day, they had their man. General Growth Properties, the company that owned them all, did not take kindly to the secret
那一刻我意识到，我内心深处明白：一切都结束了。事实证明，早些时候的入室盗窃是购物中心两个最新保安干的。他们没有清理掉所有东西，而是拿走了私人物品，希望能弄清楚迈克尔和他的朋友是谁。现在迈克尔傻乎乎地在白天回来了，他们抓住了目标。拥有该购物中心的通用成长地产公司（General Growth Properties）对墙壁内的秘密
apartment in its walls. You don't say. After being handed over to the police and interrogated, Jaffa was eventually let go. But Michael soon found himself standing in front of a judge in criminal court, charged with breaking and entering, and felony trespass. By the time I get to court, the mall is hired a lawyer,
公寓可没有什么好感。那是当然的。在被交予警方并审讯后，贾法最终被释放。但迈克尔很快发现自己站在刑事法庭的法官面前，被控非法侵入和重罪侵入。等我到法庭时，购物中心已经雇了一名律师，
and they launch into all these details about the illegal things that I have done. I keep my mouth shut. But after they've gone through this laundry list of illegal activities, they used the phrase, this gave Mr. Townsend access to an apartment that they had built over several years that had the following things in it and goes on to List in detail what the apartment looked like. Including the coffee table, the television, a coffee of the game Grand Theft Auto, an 8-foot China Hutch, a 4-piece Sectional Couch, silverware for 8 with matching glassware, a 6-foot pot.
他们开始滔滔不绝地讲述我所做过的所有非法事情。我闭口不言。但当他们列完这些非法活动的清单后，他们用了这样一句话：“这让汤森先生能够进入一个他们历时几年建造的公寓，里面有以下物品……”接着开始详细列出公寓的模样。包括咖啡桌、电视、《侠盗猎车手》游戏光盘、8英尺高的新式碗柜、4件套组合沙发、带有相配玻璃器皿的8人份银器、6英尺高的盆栽……
And the more details this little hair gives, the more the dudge just looks around. And he's like, what's happening here? And the dudge hustles advisors, close to him, and he, I hear him whispering, and then he looks up, looks me dead in the eyes, and he goes, this is not a criminal act. We're not sure exactly what it was, but this is not a criminal act. We're not sure exactly what it was.
这个律师提供的细节越多，法官就越是四处张望。他好像在想：这里发生了什么？法官召集了身边的顾问，我听到他在耳语，然后他抬起头，直视着我的眼睛，说道：“这不是刑事犯罪。”我们不确定这到底是什么，但这不是刑事犯罪。我们不确定这到底是什么，
But this is not a crime. Whether the judge was perceiving a deep legal truth at the heart of this case, or Michael was just the beneficiary of an incredible amount of white privilege, Michael may never know. In the end, he was slapped with a misdemeanor for trespassing and released. He had lived on and off in a secret apartment for nearly four years, and it was going to cost him almost nothing. But that doesn't mean he got away entirely, Scott free.
但这绝对不是犯罪。无论法官是看穿了这个案件核心深处的法律真相，还是迈克尔只是享有巨额白人特权的好处，迈克尔可能永远都不会知道了。最后，他因非法侵入被判处轻罪并被释放断。他在秘密公寓里断断续续地生活了近四年，而且几乎没有花他什么钱。但这并不意味着他完全逃脱了惩罚，逍遥法外。
Just before Michael left the mall, the mall security team handed him a piece of paper. The same piece of paper they handed to Brawler, shoplifters, and anyone else who has overstayed their welcome in this most private of public spaces. It's a standardized manila piece of paper which has a map of the mall. It has this red line around the whole thing and you have to sign it and it says you can't cross that red line. So they make it clear you're never coming back. Now, over a decade later, Michael still lives right near the mall. But his days of running anywhere near its 13 acres are over. And the biggest bummer for me is that
就在迈克尔离开购物中心之前，购物中心的安保团队递给他一张纸。就是那种递给小偷、扒手以及任何在这个最私密的公共空间里滞留过久的人的同一张纸。这是一张标准的小牛皮纸地图，上面有购物中心的地图。整张地图周围有一条红线，你必须在上面签名，上面写着你不能穿过那条红线。所以他们明确表示你永远不能回来。现在，十多年过去了，迈克尔依然住在购物中心附近。但他在这13英亩土地附近跑步的日子已经结束了。对我来说最糟糕的是，
if I want to go to downtown, the path that you bring your bike through is through the center of the malt where it bridges over the river. And now that I'm banned from the malt, I have to bike around it. And I've biked around it for 10 years. Are you serious? Diligently. I have never broken this rule.
如果我想去市中心，你骑自行车穿过的路径是穿过购物中心的中心，那里有横跨河流的桥梁。现在我被禁止进入购物中心，我不得不骑车绕过它。我已经绕着它骑了10年了。你是认真的吗？勤勤恳恳。我从来没有打破过这个规则。
So you really can never go back? I can never broken this rule. So you really can never go back? I can never go back. This story was a co-production with the KCRW podcast Nocturn, which is produced and hosted by Vanessa Lowe. Nocturn is an exploration of the night and the landscape of the unseen, with a link on the website and in the show notes. Coming up, we go back to the mall, specifically the mall that started it all, after this. Now that we've sneaked into this weird public private space that is the mall,
所以你真的永远不能回去了？我从未打破过这个规则。所以你真的永远不能回去了？我永远不能回去了。这个故事是与KCRW播客《夜曲》（Nocturn）联合制作的，该播客由凡妮莎·洛（Vanessa Lowe）制作和主持。《夜曲》是对夜晚和看不见的风景的探索，网站和节目注释中都有链接。接下来，我们将回到购物中心，特别是那个开启这一切的购物中心，广告之后见。既然我们已经潜入了作为购物中心的这个诡异的公共私人空间，
I thought it'd be fun to revisit the origin story of this incredibly intriguing location, which Avery reported for us a few years ago. We've all done it. You go to the store for a pair of socks and come out with a mega pack of soda. You go out to get shampoo and come back with a fancy razor. It's hard to stick to what's on your list. I challenge you to go to IKEA and leave with only the thing for what you game. Just try to buy a lamp without buying a cutting board.
我想重新审视这个极其迷人地点的起源故事会很有趣，艾瑞里几年前为我们作了报道。我们都做过这种事。你去商店买一双袜子，出来时却带了一大包苏打水。你出去买洗发水，回来时带了一个昂贵的剃须刀。很难坚持只买清单上的东西。我敢你去宜拉客（IKEA）时，只买你本来打算买的那样东西就离开。试着买一盏台灯而不买砧板。
It can't be done. You absolutely knew this, but retail spaces are designed to do this to you. Producer Avery Truffleman The store is trying to look so beautiful, so welcoming, the item so enticingly displayed in such vast quantity that you cannot help but be drawn in, and then drawn towards something you don't need. This is the Grooan Effect.
这是做不到的。你绝对知道这一点，但零售空间的的设计就是为了对你做这件事。制作人艾瑞里·特勒弗曼（Avery Truffleman）：商店试图看起来如此美丽、如此欢迎人，商品以如此庞大的数量诱人地展示出来，以至于你情不自禁地被吸引进去，然后被吸引向那些你根本不需要的东西。这就是“格鲁恩效应”。
The Grooan Effect, or sometimes called the Grooan Transfer, it's that moment when you walk into a store and the design of the store is so overwhelming and dazzling that you begin mindlessly consuming. The Groen Effect is named after Victor Groen. So who was Groen? He's a complicated, complex, contradictory guy. Jeff Hardwick wrote the biography of Victor Groen, who was born Victor Groenbaum. Born in Vienna in 1904, and he is Jewish in Vienna, leaves in 38.
格鲁恩效应，有时也称为格鲁恩转移，就是当你走进一家商店时，商店的设计如此势不可挡、令人眼花缭乱，以至于你开始盲目消费。格鲁恩效应是以维克托·格鲁恩（Victor Gruen）的名字命名的。那么格鲁恩是谁呢？他是一个复杂、矛盾、充满对立面的人。杰夫·哈德威克（Jeff Hardwick）写了维克托·格鲁恩的传记，他原名维克托·格鲁恩鲍姆（Victor Gruenbaum）。1904年出生于维也纳，他是维也纳的犹太人，于1938年离开。
Good call, Groenbaum. And makes his way eventually to New York City. Once in New York, Groen made a name for himself designing shops and retail spaces. And this was a particular challenge during the lean years of the late 30s. People had no money. They just wouldn't go into shops at all. But Groen figured out how to lure people inside, basically by using amazingly appealing window displays. You would go into these window display areas, look at jewelry or handbags or chocolates and then you'd be
做得好，格鲁恩鲍姆。并最终来到了纽约市。到了纽约后，格鲁恩凭借设计商店和零售空间而名声大噪。在30年代末经济萧条的艰难岁月里，这是一个特别的挑战。人们没有钱。他们根本不去商店。但格鲁恩想出了如何吸引人们进来的方法，基本上是通过使用惊人吸引人的橱窗陈列。你会走进这些橱窗陈列区，看看珠宝、手袋或巧克力，然后你就会
tempted and lured into the store. I mean that's the grue and effect. Grue and argued that good design equaled good profits. And he he equates those as one to one. If you do more people are gonna stay there longer and spend more money. Grue and started making storefronts all over the country, and he moved from New York to Los Angeles in 1941. Grewin was from the beautiful city of Vienna, which is lined with shops and greenery and places to gather. He saw how most Americans were just riding around in their cars all the time,
被诱惑并吸引进店里。我的意思是，这就是格鲁恩效应。格鲁恩认为，良好的设计等于巨额利润。他将这两者等同起来。如果你做得更多，人们会逗留更长时间并花更多的钱。格鲁恩开始在全国各地打造店面，并于1941年从纽约搬到了洛杉矶。格鲁恩来自美丽的维也纳，那里到处都是商店、绿地和聚会场所。他看到大多数美国人整天只是开着车到处跑，
cut off from the city and from each other, and he knew this problem was even worse in the suburbs. The suburbs lacked what sociologist Ray Oldenburg calls third places. Think of home as your primary place, work as your second place. And that third place is where you go to build community to hang out, to simply feel connected. Grewen wanted to give the American suburbs that third place. The image of living in closer communication with other people, the image of having the possibility from walking to one place to another. That's archival footage of Grewen from the University of Wyoming.
与城市隔离，与彼此隔离，他知道这个问题在郊区甚至更严重。郊区缺乏社会学家雷·奥尔登堡（Ray Oldenburg）所说的“第三空间”。把家当作你的第一空间，工作当作你的第二空间。而第三空间则是你去建立社区、闲逛、仅仅感受联系的地方。格鲁恩想要给美国郊区提供那个第三空间。与其他人更紧密沟通的生活意象，拥有从一个地方步行到另一个地方的可能性的意象。这是怀俄明大学保存的格鲁恩的档案镜头。
The image of participating in events outside of your own little house has become a desirable factor. Victor Groen imagined designing an environment full of greenery and shops, an indoor plaza, a modern forum, an island of connection in the middle of the sprawl, one that would only be accessible to pedestrians. Because old man, Victor Grewen hated cars. He rants and raves against cars continually. One technological event has swamped us.
参与自己小房子之外的活动已成为一个受欢迎的因素。维克托·格鲁恩设想设计一个充满绿地和商店的环境、一个室内广场、一个现代论坛、一个在蔓延城市中间的连接之岛，一个只能由行人进入的地方。因为老头子维克托·格鲁恩讨厌汽车。他不断地对汽车大加斥责和咆哮。有一个技术事件淹没了我们。
That is the advent of the rubber wheel vehicle, the private car, the truck, the trailer, as means of mass transportation. And they're threat. To human life and tense, he is just as great as that of the exposed sewer. It's hard to understand them with the tape hiss in the accent, but what Grooen is saying there is. The threat of cars to human life and health is as great as the exposed sewer.
那就是橡胶轮车辆、私家车、卡车、拖车作为大众交通工具的出现。它们的威胁。对人类生命和健康的威胁与露天污水沟一样大。很难理解他们在磁带沙沙声和口音中所说的话，但格鲁恩在那里所说的是。汽车对人类生命和健康的威胁与露天污水沟一样大。
So Grooen's objective was to get people to park their cars far away from these third places and walk and stroll within them. As Groen saw it, his structure would be an architectural panacea. It would remedy environmental, commercial, and sociological problems with the creation of a single building. And so, Groen presented his solution for America, the shopping mall. Groen actually wanted the shopping mall to be more than just shops. He wants them to be mixed use. He wants apartments and offices or medical centers attached to the shopping center.
所以格鲁恩的目标是让人把车停在远离这些第三空间的地方，并在其中步行漫步。在格鲁恩看来，他的建筑将是一剂建筑万灵药。它将通过建造单一建筑来解决环境、商业和社会学问题。于是，格鲁恩提出了他针对美国的解决方案——购物中心。格鲁恩实际上希望购物中心不仅仅是商店。他希望它们是混合用途的。他希望将公寓、办公室或医疗中心附属于购物中心。
He makes cases to have child care facilities, libraries, bomb shelters, a whole range of different functions. And Groen dreamed and wrote about being closed shopping center way before he ever built one. Until he finally lands a commission for the very first indoor climate controlled shopping center. In Adina, Minnesota, a place not known for its welcoming climate. Southdale represents an entirely new and dramatic concept in retail merchandising. Southdale Center opened in 1956, and it was the mother of all shopping malls.
他提出设立托儿所、图书馆、防空洞以及各种各样不同的功能。早在建造第一个室内空调购物中心之前，格鲁恩就梦想并撰文谈论封闭式购物中心。直到他最终获得为第一个室内恒温购物中心进行设计的委托。在明尼苏达州的埃迪纳（Edina），一个不以宜人气候闻名的地 方。绍代尔代表了零售营销中一个全新且戏剧性的概念。绍代尔中心于1956年开业，它是所有购物中心的鼻祖。
Seriously, ruined subsequent malls were all mostly based off this original adina design. When he's doing the first enclosed shopping mall, Southdale, in a dynaminisoda, but Groo and really emphasize and what the media ends up celebrating is this massive center court. This court has enclosed and skylighted, so but not only the stores, but the shopping sidewalks. In fact, the whole area in front of the stores is air-conditioned and temperature controlled, a year-round climate of 72 degrees. For Groen, he's creating a town square.
真的，后来的所有购物中心基本上都是以这个最初的埃迪纳设计为基础的。当他在明尼苏达州埃迪纳建造第一个封闭式购物中心绍代尔时，格鲁恩真正强调的以及媒体最终庆贺的是这个巨大的中央庭院。这个庭院是封闭的并且有天窗，所以不仅是商店，还有购物人行道。事实上，商店前面的整个区域都是装有空调和温度控制的，全年维持72度的气候。对格鲁恩来说，他正在创造一个城镇广场。
Southdale Center wasn't quite mixed use, like Groen imagined. People didn't live in it, and something like a daycare center or a post office couldn't afford that rent. But Southdale did have local shops of all kinds, and plenty of shoppers. Southdale, tomorrow's main street, today. But from the outside, Southdale Center is not much to look at. I mean, it looks like a mall. It's a ominous, amorphous boxy shape. In designing these shopping malls, Groen ended his razzle dazzle storefronts and window displays. Southdale hardly has exterior
绍代尔中心并不完全像格鲁恩想象的那样是混合用途的。人们不住在里面，像日托中心或邮局这样的机构也付不起那里的租金。但绍代尔确实拥有各种各样的当地商店，以及大量的购物者。绍代尔，明天的主要街道，今天。但从外部来看，绍代尔中心并没有什么好看的。我的意思是，它看起来像个购物中心。这是一个不祥的、无定形的方块形状。在设计这些购物中心时，格鲁恩结束了他那些耀眼的店面和橱窗陈列。绍代尔几乎没有外部
windows at all. He moves away from the original concept that in some ways they're going to attract by being ostentatious. The draw now is what's inside the mall. In Groen's mind, it should have pretty much a blank facade, no signage on it, and then you enter that space, and then you walk into the shopping center, and that's that sort of transformational Grooons transfer moment. Moles are designed as these sort of suburban pilgrimage sites, which of course you have to drive to. It's a commitment. You're driving 20, 30 minutes, you're parking, you're getting out of your car, you're walking in. Grewin knew that Americans love to drive, so the mall was his compromise.
窗户。他抛弃了最初的理念——即它们在某种程度上会通过浮夸来吸引人。现在的吸引力是购物中心内部的东西。在格鲁恩看来，它应该基本上有一个空白的外墙，上面没有标牌，然后你进入那个空间，然后你走进购物中心，那就是那种转型式的格鲁恩转移时刻。购物中心被设计成这种郊区朝圣地，当然你必须开车去。这是一个承诺。你开车20、30分钟，你停车，你下车，你走进去。格鲁恩知道美国人喜欢开车，所以购物中心是他的妥协。
You had to walk and stroll once you were inside, but the customers could drive over. So he just hates the automobile, but he never will acknowledge that he's creating these shopping centers, which are largely only accessible through cars. Ruin was right. Americans loved driving to his malls. He got commissions for them all over the country. But over time, Gruin sees that interacting these malls, these tiny suburban cities, he's
一旦你进去了，你必须步行和漫步，但顾客可以开车过来。所以他只是讨厌汽车，但他永远不会承认他正在创造这些购物中心，而这些购物中心在很大程度上只能通过汽车进入。格鲁恩是对的。美国人喜欢开车去他的购物中心。他在全国各地接到了设计它们的委托。但随着时间的推移，格鲁恩看到通过建立这些购物中心、这些微型郊区城市，他正在
helping to drain the real cities. And so for a while, Gruen shifts his focus to urban planning. We want to rescue our cities, which because we haven't neglected our threatening to go to pieces. And so Gruen ends up being involved in urban renewal projects where he draws directly on some of the lessons learned in his suburban shopping malls and proposes bringing them back downtown.
帮助掏空真正的城市。所以有一段时间，格鲁恩将重点转移到了城市规划上。我们要拯救我们的城市，由于我们的忽视，它们正面临崩溃的危险。因此，格鲁恩最终参与了城市更新项目，他直接借鉴了从郊区购物中心学到的一些教训，并提议将它们带回市中心。
Municipalities hire Grooen and associates to make their downtowns more like malls. Grooen turns city centers into pedestrian-only spaces full of public art and greenery and lined with shops. He made plans for Boulder, Fresno, Fort Worth, Kalamazoo. Actually, his plan for Kalamazoo became the first outdoor pedestrian shopping mall in the US. He even had a concept to turn Fifth Avenue into a pedestrian mall. He gets Manhattan to close down Fifth Avenue for a couple weeks as a test.
市政当局聘请格鲁恩及其合伙人让他们的市中心更像购物中心。格鲁恩将市中心变成只能由行人进入的空间，里面充满了公共艺术和绿地，并排满了商店。他为博尔德、弗雷斯诺、沃斯堡、卡拉马祖制定了计划。事实上，他为卡拉马祖制定的计划成为了美国第一个户外步行购物中心。他甚至有一个将第五大道变成步行购物中心的构想。他让曼哈顿关闭第五大道几周作为测试。
But a city's downtown is not a mall. It's not so easily quote unquote fixed, not so perfectly designed and controlled. Cities weren't going to become the pleasant, sterile shopping environments that Groen wanted them to be. After the riots of the 60s, he is shocked and sort of taken aback by those and was very much unprepared for them. And I think that may have been somewhat of his reason for the retreat to Vienna.
但城市的市中心不是购物中心。它没那么容易被所谓“修复”，也没那么完美地设计和控制。城市不会变成格鲁恩希望它们成为的那个令人愉快、无菌的购物环境。60年代暴动之后，他对那些感到震惊并有点吃惊，并且非常没有准备好应对它们。我认为这可能是他退回维也纳的部分原因。
In 1968, Groen moved from Los Angeles back to Vienna, back to the Greenery and Plaza's. He had been trying to imitate. But he could not escape his own creation. There's a shopping mall that's being built on the edge of Vienna. And he points to that as how that shopping mall is destroying downtown Vienna. In Groen's mind,
1968年，格鲁恩从洛杉矶搬回维也纳，回到了绿地和广场。他一直在试图模仿这些。但他无法逃避他自己的创造。维也纳边缘正在建造一个购物中心。他指出那个购物中心是如何摧毁维也纳市中心的。在格鲁恩的看来，
Vienna was already perfectly planned. It didn't need a mall like the broken American suburbs did. As he saw it, his original vision had been completely skewed. After being in Vienna about 10 years, he gives a speech and writes a paper where he says, I refuse to pay alimony for these bastard developments. Victor Gruehn, the mall maker, became the foremost mall critic. And meanwhile, America's love affair with malls continued. Did you want to pass the mall?
维也纳已经规划得很完美了。它不需要像破碎的美国郊区那样的购物中心。在他看来，他最初的愿景已经被彻底扭曲了。在维也纳呆了大约10年之后，他发表了一篇演讲并写了一篇论文，在其中他说道：“我拒绝为这些杂种开发项目支付赡养费。”购物中心的创造者维克托·格鲁恩，成为了最重要的购物中心批评家。与此同时，美国对购物中心的爱情仍在继续。你想去购物中心吗？
It's a pretty girl like you doing sitting alone in the middle of this money, to consumerism. Let's go to the mall! I know I remember in my own experience growing up in New Jersey when the first mall opened anywhere near me when I was in high school. This is Ellen Dunham Jones. She's a professor of architecture and urban design at Georgia Tech. It was cool to go to the mall, but I mean literally it was air conditioned. My home wasn't air conditioned, my school wasn't air conditioned.
像你这样的漂亮女孩怎么独自坐在金钱和消费主义的中间。我们去购物中心吧！我知道，我记得我自己在在新泽西州长大的经历，当我在高中时，离我最近的第一个购物中心开业了。这是埃伦·邓纳姆·琼斯（Ellen Dunham Jones）。她是佐治亚理工学院的建筑和城市设计教授。去购物中心很酷，但我的意思是字面意思是它有空调。我的家没有空调，我的学校没有空调。
Today, most of us are spending our days and our nights in completely thermally controlled environments. A lot of us are craving being able to be outdoors. In recent decades our tastes have veered away from climate controlled environments and away from the indoor mall. Mall construction actually peaked in 1990. It's been declining ever since and by 2006 is really the last brand new kind of standard conventional mall that's been built in the US. And a new product has entered the scene, a kind of shopping center that the ICSC, the International Council of Shopping Centers, calls a Lifestyle centers started appearing in the 90s and they tend to be open air so you don't have that roof anymore, but you have a lot of boutiques and a lot more restaurants.
今天，我们大多数人的白天和黑夜都在完全温控的环境中度过。我们中的许多人渴望能够去户外。近几十年来，我们的品味已经从温控环境和室内购物中心转向。购物中心建设实际上在1990年达到顶峰。从那以后一直在下降，到2006年实际上是美国建造的最后一个全新类型的标准传统购物中心。一种新产品进入了市场，一种被ICSC（国际购物中心理事会）称为生活方式中心的购物中心，开始在90年代出现，它们往往是露天的，所以你不再有那个屋顶，但你有很多精品店和更多的餐厅。
Lifestyle centers are malls disguised as main streets. Even though they're full of chain stores, lifestyle centers are sunny and walkable and bustling, and kind of what Victor grew and imagined. And some of the old-style indoor shopping malls are being repurposed. Several of them are being retrofitted into Hispanic community centers, like in Plaza Fiesta outside of Atlanta. A lot of the stores have been cut up into much smaller mom and pop, small shops,
生活方式中心是伪装成主要街道的购物中心。尽管它们里面都是连锁店，但生活方式中心阳光充足、适合步行、熙熙攘攘，有点像维克托·格鲁恩所想象的那样。一些老式的室内购物中心正在被改作他用。其中几个被改造为西班牙裔社区中心，就像亚特兰大郊外的广场节日（Plaza Fiesta）那样。许多商店被分割成更小的夫妻店、小型商店，
selling western ware, selling cantonera dresses. Plaza Fiesta also has a steady events calendar of performances. In this too was kind of what grew and imagined. These sort of community malls are truly places to gather and spend money in the shell of the failed design. Most people architectural historians especially, they grew and was a horrible architect. And you know, I can see where they're coming from. I mean, his exteriors of his building are uniformly boring. But for grew and that wasn't the point. It was Groen, that wasn't the point. It was the interiors that were really the point. Those fountains, the cheesy statues,
售卖西部服装，售卖坎托内拉连衣裙。Plaza Fiesta 还有一份稳定的活动演出日程表。这也是某种滋生和构想出来的东西。这类社区购物中心确实是在失败设计的空壳中聚集和消费的场所。大多数人，尤其是建筑历史学家，他们认为格鲁恩是个糟糕的建筑师。你知道的，我能理解他们的想法。我的意思是，他建筑的外观千篇一律地枯燥。但对格鲁恩来说，重点并非如此。对格鲁恩而言，重点并不是外在。重点其实在于内部。那些喷泉、俗气的雕像，
the elevator music piped in through all those speakers, those are all part of the Groen effect, and they helped turn shopping malls into spaces where we felt comfortable staying and spending time and money. A lot of the original indoor malls are abandoned now. Seriously, like some of them are growing weeds inside. There's a website that's become sort of a graveyard of deadmalls called deadmalls.com. Users can log on and submit stories of the deadmalls in their towns.
通过所有扬声器播放的轻松背景音乐，这些都是格鲁恩效应的一部分，它们帮助把购物中心变成了让我们乐意逗留、消磨时间和金钱的空间。许多最初的室内购物中心现在都被废弃了。说真的，其中一些里面都长满杂草了。有一个网站成了死气沉沉的购物中心的墓地，叫做 deadmalls.com。用户可以登录并提交他们城镇中消亡购物中心的故事。
There are around 450 malls listed there, submitted as sort of oral histories. In particular, what's interesting, I think, about deadmalls.com is how nostalgic a lot of this is. And it does make sense. I mean, in so many suburban communities, the mall became the de facto town center. It was really the center of social life other than the school. I would be very sad if all of Victor Grunz malls were demolished. We should certainly work to
那里列出了大约 450 个购物中心，以某种口述历史的形式提交。特别有意思的是，我认为 deadmalls.com 充满了一种怀旧情怀。这确实合乎情理。我的意思是，在如此多的郊区社区里，购物中心成了事实上的市中心。除了学校之外，它确实是社交生活的中心。如果维克托·格鲁恩的所有购物中心都被拆毁，我会非常难过。我们当然应该努力
preserve at least one. The most famous mall in Minnesota may be the mall of America. With its roller coaster, its zipline, its aquarium, and water park. But the most architecturally significant mall, its grandfather, is the one that's just a 12-minute drive away in a diner. Jeff Hardwick's book is called Mallmaker, Victor grue an architect of an American dream. An Ellen Dunham Jones book is called Retro-Fitting Suburbania, special thanks to Claire Dordy for research help.
至少保护其中一个。明尼苏达州最著名的购物中心也许是美国商城（Mall of America）。里面有它的过山车、高空滑索、水族馆和水上乐园。但最具建筑意义的购物中心、它的鼻祖，是那个驱车仅需 12 分钟便可到达、位于伊代纳（Edina）的商城。杰夫·哈德威克（Jeff Hardwick）的书名为《造城者：美国梦的建筑师维克托·格鲁恩》。埃伦·邓纳姆-琼斯（Ellen Dunham Jones）的书名为《改造郊区》，特别感谢克莱尔·多迪（Claire Dordy）提供的研究帮助。
Part 1 of 99% of his book was produced by Vanessa Lo from Nocturne and Joe Rosenberg. Mixing Tech Production by Sharif Yusuf Music by Sean Rial. Part 2 was produced by Avery Trouffleman in early 2015. Katie Mingle is our senior producer, Kurt Colstead is the digital director. The rest of the team is senior editor, Delaney Hall, Emmett Fitzgerald, Vivian Lee, Terran Mazza, and me, Roman Mars. You can find Vanessa Lowe's haunting show, Nocturn,
99% 节目第一部分由来自 Nocturne 的凡妮莎·洛（Vanessa Lowe）和乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）制作。混音技术制作：谢里夫·优素福（Sharif Yusuf），音乐：肖恩·里尔（Sean Rial）。第二部分由艾弗里·特鲁夫曼（Avery Trouffleman）于 2015 年初制作。凯蒂·明格尔（Katie Mingle）是我们的资深制作人，库尔特·科尔斯特德（Kurt Kohlstedt）是数字总监。团队的其他成员包括高级编辑德兰妮·霍尔（Delaney Hall）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、薇薇安·李（Vivian Lee）、泰兰·马扎（Terran Mazza）以及我，罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。你可以在
at NocturnPodcast.org. We are a project of 91.7 K-A-L-W in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
NocturnPodcast.org 上找到凡妮莎·洛令人难忘的节目《Nocturne》。我们是旧金山 91.7 KALW 的一个项目，在美丽加州奥克兰市中心的 Radio Row 制作。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。